IS PREDICATED FROM COMING DOWN
THE HILL.
HE'S DEVELOPED A JUMP SHOT, BUT
I THINK IT WOULD BE TOUGH FOR
HIM TO BE WHO HE IS TODAY BACK
THEN.
KRISTEN: WHAT SAY YOU,
BASKETBALL FANS?
WOULD GIANNIS BE AN M.V.P.
CALIBER PLAYER IN THE 80'S AND
90'S?
YES OR NO.
ZEKE, IN THE 80'S?
ISIAH: ABSOLUTELY.
KRISTEN: I HAD A FEELING.
ISIAH: LET'S BE FOR REAL.
I REMEMBER IN THE 1980'S THERE
WAS A GUY BY THE NAME OF RALPH
SAMPSON.
RALPH SAMPSON AND HAKEEM
OLAJUWON -- AND BEFORE RALPH
SAMPSON GOT HURT, THEY WERE
SAYING, BILL RUSSELL WAS SAYING
RALPH SAMPSON CAN BE THE
GREATEST PLAYER EVER BECAUSE OF
HIS SKILL SET AND ABILITY TO
HANDLE THE BALL AND PLAY AROUND
THE BASKETS, HIS ABILITY TO
BLOCK SHOTS.
GIANNIS IS TODAY'S RALPH SAMPSON
APPEARED ALL OF THESE GUYS
TALKING ABOUT IF GIANNIS CAN
PLAY, GIANNIS GOING AROUND
OAKLEY, HE'S DUNKING ON THEM.
HE'S BIGGER.
HE'S FASTER.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT ALL OF THAT
STUFF BECAUSE YOU DON'T PLAY NO
MORE.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT ALL OF THAT
STUFF BECAUSE YOU HAVE GRAY HAIR
AND ARE SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES.
THAT DUDE WOULD DOG YOU EVERY
SINGLE TIME YELL STEPPED ON THE
COURT.
YOU MAY HIT HIM HARD.
OK.
AFTER YOU HIT HIM HARD, YOU
AIN'T GOT NO GAME.
IF YOU HIT ME, AND I'M LIKE,
THAT'S ALL YOU'VE GOT, I'M
GETTING READY TO MESS OVER YOU.
GIANNIS, JUST LIKE HE IS
TREATING THEM, HE'S BIGGER,
FASTER, STRONGER.
HE'D BE DUNKING ON ALL OF THEM,
JUST LIKE RALPH SAMPSON WAS.
ALL OF Y'ALL, STOP IT.
WE AIN'T EVER SEEN NO DUDE LIKE
THIS COME INTO OUR LEAGUE.